A while back, the person class had the ability to return the number of friends
someone has. We printed the number of friends like this, which works pretty
well most of the time. But what if you only have one friend? It would print
out, this person has 1 friends. If you want a program to look professional and
have output with good grammar, you often need to have the plural form and the
singular form of a word. We're going to tackle that problem in a minute. But in
preparation, let's write a word class with a method for figuring out if a
letter is a consonant or a vowel. Here's the word class. It saves its letters
in an instance variable, letters. The is vowel method takes in an index, and
then checks to see if the letter at that index is an a. You've probably noticed
that this method implementation doesn't really match the description of the
method. isVowel should recognize a, e, i, o, and u. Call y a consonant for now.
This isConsonant method is completely empty at the moment. It's your turn. Fix
the condition in isVowel and implement the isConsonant method. Here's a hint,
you shouldn't need to do 21 checks to implement isConsonant.